hostiles so the story of nights the
Fallen Empire it's a dark time for the
galaxy this eternal Empire has crushed
every other force in the universe so
it's up to you to recruit an alliance
that together can stand against the
eternal Empire and hopefully defeat them
despite these overwhelming odds against
you in the upcoming chapter disavowed
the Outlander is on a dangerous mission
deep behind enemy lines looking to
recruit havoc squad these are the most
elite soldiers in the entire galaxies
that Navy SEALs are Delta Force of the
Star Wars universe major Jorgen is the
commander of havoc squad so the most
elite of the elite and he takes great
pride in being a leader to his soldiers
we've got incoming regs for a fight
having these are going to be the kind of
heroes you need in order to achieve your
mission something that no one else could
do in this chapter you're going to
uncover a vital piece of intelligence a
huge revelation about how the eternal
Empire operates something that's going
to change the shape of the war and give
the Outlander the advantage they so
desperately need against their enemy
it's a great chance to jump in anytime
you want it's going to be an awesome
chapter I can't wait till everyone plays
it it's gonna be a dangerous mission so
a good luck out there
you